to talk about this
being in touch with something that is
more real than real
and let's just go straight there to
mckenna before we return to the bigger
picture so he's talked about the uh what
is it self-healing machine self
self-transforming self-transforming
machine i was during his uh
dmt
travels
and uh i just talked to rick goblin who
also had different travels through this
hyperspace
but they all seem to be traveling on the
same spaceship just to different
locations and there is a sense in which
they seem to be traveling
through whatever i don't know if it's
through spacetime or something else to
meet
something that is more real than real uh
what can you say about this dmt
experience about terence mckenna about
the poetry he used but maybe more
specifically about this place that they
seem to all travel to
so the big question is is it real is it
really more real than real the ancient
philosophers were asking the same
question and
their means of attempting to answer that
was by dying um so if you ask plato the
definition of philosophy he will say
that to practice it in the right way
is to practice dying and being dead and
many people
describe the psychedelic experience in
sort of near-death experience terms
and the encountering of all this visual
imagery tends to be something that is
often described as more real than real
so how does terence talk about this so i
was just listening to the trialogs which
folks should look up somewhere between
1989 and 1990 terence sits down
uh with his friends uh ralph abraham and
rupert sheldrake at esslin and they're
they're trying to figure out the meaning
of these discarnate entities and these
non-human intelligences
and terence develops a taxonomy
for how to analyze this and he says that
number one
they're either
um
semi-physical
but kind of elusive so think of the
bigfoot or the yeti or things like this
um beings that exist somewhere between
mythology and zoology um which is isn't
really appropriate here so so uh option
number two
he says is the mental i'm sorry
you're dropping so many good lines it's
so good okay i apologize
[Laughter]
somewhere between nostalgia and zouave
this is all terence mckenna okay all
right i take no credit for this uh so
but you're combining you're like uh jimi
hendrix only used the blues scale but
he's still uh he still created something
new in in the music you played anyway go
ahead well we're going into mixolydian
right now okay so um
uh so uh option number two and this is
this what this is what uh terence calls
sort of the mentalist reductionist
approach um and this is this is pure
mechanic poetry he says that these
beings could be
autonomous fragments of psychic energy
that have temporarily escaped the
controlling power of the ego
um so in union senses these would just
be pure projections um the projections
of schizophrenics in some cases so
they're essentially unreal and the third
option the most tantalizing
is that they're both non-physical
but autonomous in other words they
actually exist
in some kind of real place
in some kind of real space and that we
can have congress with them there is
communication he talks about um the
whisperings of the demon artificers and
that it's just possible
that our meetings with these beings have
coaxed the human species
into self-expression in a very real way
that at different times in history our
relationships with these
semi-autonomous beings may actually
guide the species now this is
high speculation
and uh terence
and ralph and rupert wind up talking
about the early modern period and the
scientific enlightenment and that even
someone like descartes reports a dream
in which
he came face to face with an angel who
said that the conquest of nature
is to be achieved uh through measure and
number so so even the hard-minded
materialist like like descartes is
confronting these discarnate entities
john d in the 16th century the high
magician of the elizabethan court
he reports decades worth of what we
would say is extraterrestrial
communication or interdimensional
communication
and you can find instances of this
throughout history including among the
pre-socratics
and peter kingsley writes quite a bit
about this
you